I think one of the really scary and
overwhelming things about terrorism can
be the idea that it's this giant Boogie
man that is really difficult to
comprehend and is terrifying and comes
along in the night out of nowhere and
steals your family members or loved ones
away.
And for me,
my life's work has really been
understanding the small logical puzzle
pieces that when taken together create
that man so that you can take it apart
into manageable pieces and actually
begin to understand what drives these
inconceivable actions.
So when you take this overwhelming
boogie man of terrorism and you begin to
tease it apart based on the data and
look for patterns,
the turnoff again and again,
each time a terrorist plot is planned in
a different territory throughout the
historical data,
you begin to notice patterns that might
not seem obvious to begin with.
So things like the percentage beneath
livable wage that a border guard gets
paid,
which of course gives rise to the
possibility of accepting a bribe to let
somebody just sneak across the border or
hand to package to you if that bribe is
the difference between being able to
feed your kids that months or not.
It's a pretty understandable small
choice for that individual actor and yet
has given rise to perhaps a terrorist
act to being able to take place even
though the law of the territory should
have prevented it.
Another example would be the rate of
change of things like freedom of the
press or freedom of speech,
not the scores themselves,
but the rate of change which goes to the
difficulty that society's experience
when they suddenly open up and allow
liberties that many of the more
traditional members of society haven't
been accustomed to in the past.
There are strategies for taking
communities through those evolutions.
But without those strategies in place,
it can seem very jarring.
And we experienced that even in a mature
democracy like ours where when certain
changes take place quickly,
it can take portions of the community
time to be comfortable with them and to
catch up in a political environment.
Um,
another example would be the ratio of
who Kabar is to Madrasa was,
and there you begin to see,
you know,
tensions between more traditional
religious elements in society and a
younger demographic in many countries
where you have more than 50% in that
youth demographic.
There's a big cultural rift there that
can often give rise to lack of
understanding or the feeling that young
people are not being incorporated into
society and need some other outlet for,
uh,
for their feelings of,
of frustration.
And,
and eventually,
um,
another really interesting one that we
see is how good machine translation is
for a local language.
So often we think that libraries in in
the olden days and and now the provision
of hardware and Internet access points
can be a great uh,
tool in the fight against extremism.
All of a sudden young people in a given
area have access to the sum total of
human knowledge.
How great is that?
And yet if the language that's spoken,
the dialect in that region is not very
well translated by Google translator or
other artificial intelligence programs,
then really access to the Internet for
the majority of young people who don't
necessarily speak another language or
dialect is not terribly meaningful
because they're generally seeing sights
that for small dialect are actually
created in their vicinity and may not
offer perspectives that are particularly
different from what they're hearing
around them in a given day.
So there are a number of these
correlations and the beauty,
you know,
my dad's a,
an economist and I grew up in a
household that loved throwing data
around around the dinner table.
And the beauty of data is that you can
look at huge sets across many different
time periods and geographies and see
patterns that emerged so starkly that
you can't ignore them.
These kinds of inputs are really helpful
in understanding how regular human
beings like you and me,
who grew up in different environments,
subject to different inputs,
could find themselves with different
perspectives about what's happening in
the world.
And eventually if their perspectives go
unheard,
feel increasing frustration that
eventually can find its outlet in a
violent way.
Well,
what's one of the things that I think is
very interesting outside of those just
being intellectually interesting,
one of the practical applications of
that kind of study is to see where there
are easy,
cheap,
efficient ways to make,
uh,
a disproportionately big impact in
portions of the world where instead of
launching a kind of nebulous
multimillion dollar program that maybe
is not going to hit the milestones that
it's intending to hit,
you can go in with a very surgical and
efficient programs and make a
disproportionately large impact in the
lives of the people living in those
regions.
Okay.